hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled single cell mapping of
human brain cancer
reveals tumor-driven education of
tumor-associated
leukocytes i'm susie valdez of labyrinth
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
fluidon so let's get started before we
begin
i want to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you'd
like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's
speaker dr burkhard fetcher professor
and chairman at the institute of
experimental immunology
at the university of zurich for a
complete biography on dr badger please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
architecture welcome please begin your
presentation
welcome sir
hello everyone thank you for the kind
introduction
my name is bokadesha and i'm happy to be
here
being here obviously means in my home
office where many of you i guess
also are banned for
the last couple of months but
i'm happy to share some work with you
that just recently
uh saw the light of day in this work by
catalina freewa
on the single cell mapping of human
brain cancer and how
we think we found out how tumors drive
the education
of leukocytes within the tumor
microenvironment
and uh let me see whether i can advance
the science here so i
quickly this this rather not so pretty
picture on the right is a
is a is a picture of a glioblastom which
is
a very uh the most common primary brain
cancer it's a very aggressive brain
tumor the prognosis is
really really bad even though it does
not metastasize is
highly invasive and
surgeons as you can imagine cannot
remove as much tissue as they would like
because the brain
is one of those tissues that is
you know rather non-redundant and it
needs to so not much
and doesn't regenerate very easily so
removal is very limited and so the
patients basically
get chemo and radiotherapy which does
not work and the majority of cases the
median survival is certainly less than
two years
and people have attempted uh checkpoint
inhibition and immunotherapy of
uh patients with glioblastoma and they
largely failed and so
what is the consensus is that
glioblastoma multiforme
or astrocytoma where we'll talk about
this in a second is is what you call a
cold
tumor now i i would
like to and it sounds as if this was the
initial plan that we had in the lab but
there's a reason why i'm presenting the
data this way where i start with
glioblastoma specifically and then i go
back a second and say what is actually
brain cancer
and i didn't answer that because there
are different kinds of brain cancers so
let me just quickly just say
what we see what we call glioma can be
this diffuse astrocytoma
and uh and other different other
uh gliomas but uh the worst of those is
as i mentioned earlier this
um uh grade four glioblastoma
astrocytoma
and that is the the the nasty uh
horrible uh and and and disease with a
very very poor prognosis
but brain cancer and so the other thing
i should mention here just
for clarification the difference between
a grade three and the grade for the
lower grade tumors and the high grade
glioblastoma
appears to be a mutation in this
in idh1 so idh1 wild-type tumors
the non-mutated ones are the aggressive
one whereas the mutated ones
are actually not as aggressive and may
just represent
a different tumor entity altogether
but brain cancer is also
and perhaps even more common
the site of metastasis so melanoma
and and carcinoma and influenza lung
cancer do metastasize in the into the
brain
and um and and that is basically the
start of our study and and and the
questions we had is is there a
difference between them when it comes to
the tumor microenvironments in other
words
is the tumor microenvironment of brain
cancer in general
shaped by the particularly unique
structure of the central nervous system
so by this uh let's say it used to be
called immune privilege
of the brain and a particular micro
environment is that shaping the tumor
micro environment
or is actually the tumor micro
environment specific to the kind
of cancer that happens to be in the
brain so it's dictating so it's the
tumor cells that dictate
the behavior of the leukocyte and the
tumor microenvironment compartment
and another introduction i'd like to
give here is the brain is also
a complicated side when it comes to the
resident
population of of of leukocyte
in particular when it comes to the
macrophage so
the macrophages of the brain the tissue
resident macrophages of the brain
are almost all of them are actually
so-called microglia cells and they come
from a very early embryonic precursor
derived
macrophage in fact from from the yolk
sac so they populate the brain early
early during development
and then that is a self-repopulating
self-sustaining population of of
phagocytes that live in the brain
and when we're having this discussion
what is the tumor-associated macrophage
so in the brain you'd have to think of
the microglia
as the primary tumor-associated
macrophage but at the same time
the pathogenic insult so the the change
of
an alteration in homeostasis in the
brain
leads to the influx of of inflammatory
cells such as
monocyte derived cells that we call
monocyte macrophages
and they those cells then will be
also tumor-associated macrophages
so on the one hand you have the cns
resident population of macrophages
responding to the kind of cancer
or to cancer in general to cancer cells
within the brain
and on the other hand depending on the
level of
leukocyte invasion you have monocyte
derived cells
and and other macrophages and other
phagocytes moving into the central
nervous system from the outside
and the problem is we talk about tams a
lot but
it's a rather diffuse
diffused entity by the definition of
being a tumor-associated macrophage
and it may very well be and we assume
that
the resident population of macrophages
and the invading population of
macrophages have significantly different
behavior in the context of cancer and
maybe even in the context of patient
outcomes and this is a particularly
problem to study is well suited
to use high dimensional cytometry
now single cell technologies is the one
i put this little slide in here just
simply because i'm annoyed sometimes by
people saying oh yeah we did some single
cell analysis
and we found this and present this and
they usually refer to single cell rna
sequencing technologies which we're
using in the lab as well
but i'd like to just point out that
immunologists have been using
single cell technologies since a very
very long time so the first fluorescent
base
uh flow cytometer was is actually older
than i am
um not not much but it's older than me
and then first multicolored flow
cytometry
became basically with uh in in in the
70s 80s
and and then basically eleventh color
flow cytometry in 2001 was the first
first time somebody showed an eleven
parameter closer down three i don't
wanna
in this particular with this particular
audience i don't have to tell you the
power of
one additional parameter and what it
does um
you can see here however what i wanted
to stress is that i believe the
technology of single cell cytometry
to have a couple of features which are
obviously potentially even superior to
what we see with single cell rna
sequencing
in particular when it comes to the
amount of throughput
that we're using but by now i mean this
this publication is a few years uh old
from which i stole this picture
but um we have the third class the third
generation mass ethometer is on and
there is constantly more development
again in this
setting i don't have to explain this to
the audience but there's a technology i
personally also find quite interesting
which is spectral analysis
that is now basically
can be considered quite competition to
mass cytometry
but let's just move to the data this is
a picture of the
two um uh investigators in our team
there's a catharina and susana
and they worked on this project together
and
basically what they decided to do and
it's also because of the
collaborators that we have at the
university hospital here
and at the neuro-oncology and
neurosurgery department is that we have
unique and privileged access to tissue
that is extras that is resected from
patient brains and that we
at first glance did not know what kind
of brain cancer tissue we were getting
here so we would make a single cell
suspension
run it through the mass cytometer and
have
you know in this case 74 different
markers and here on the um
you see this dimensionality reduction
image i forgot whether it's a tisny or
umab or what have you but the point is
what you're seeing here
is that we can clearly see demarcate
populations clearly identify them
uh i will not share the heat map and all
the details with you
but um basically see that there's a
rather rich environment this is now from
a composite image
of all the different samples that we
have analyzed
but when you when you then ask the
question so the first question i
mentioned earlier that
we had was is the
type of cancer dictate into a
microenvironment or are they all
basically dictated by the brain and this
answer
was was rather easy to to to find
this this question was rather easy to
answer as you can see here on the on on
the right side this is basically um
a pca plot that clearly shows that
glioma and metastasis cluster
completely separately and and really
crisply differently
so the while the glioma samples cluster
in this one spot the metastasis cluster
in a different spot and you might
want to know so pca there is not the
most sophisticated way of analyzing
because
this is a linear pca of analyzing
nonlinear data
but this is basically driven by t cells
so in metastasis
we find this accumulation of of t
lymphocytes
that are relatively rare in the
different glioma entities and so as a
control
what we see here is we use them
throughout the
the presentation and all the data are
relying on patients
with epilepsy mutated gliomas wild-type
gliomas or glioblastomas
and metastasis and um separated here in
these five different
tumor entities it was interesting to us
to see that the
treatment for instance with antibodies
to co-inhibitory molecules
did not influence this clustering at all
so t cells are dominant in
metastasis and we don't see them so much
obviously in the in the in the brain
endogenous cancer the cancer that comes
from a
of neuronal our origin of neural origin
and epilepsy is is the closest we could
get to healthy
brain fresh healthy brain from a living
patient
because uh as you can imagine uh
getting tissue from it's difficult to
find donors obviously of brain
but epilepsy we thought is the close the
closest approximation to healthy brain
and you can see here uh in this image
that there are very few t-cells and
epilepsy brains
um but let's just quickly go a little
bit deeper into the data and look at for
instance these so-called tams the
tumor-associated macrophages
and what we did and we
did this for quite a while now both in
mouse and main to make sure that we know
the difference the phenotypic difference
between a microglia
between a monocyte that is blood derived
and the monocytes-derived
macrophage we call them here other
people call them monocyte-derived
dendritic cells or monocyte-derived
cells in general here we just call them
mdms
and we use mice in addition to what we
will be doing this is i only show you
human data but let me assure you that
we know for instance the expression of
cd49d
is exclusive to blood derived cells
so the microglia are cd49d negative
we verified that also by histology and
and by
by fate mapping in mice and we've done a
lot of extra effort
it's all in in the paper if you're
interested you can you can read this it
just came out
earlier this year you can see that
the monocytes and monoxide derive
macrophages are clearly different from
the microglia but now we can look at
these cells
in some more detail and um now that we
identified this
and and you can see here again let me
just go back one slide i apologize
you can see once again on on the upper
left panel
you see this tiffany blot that i showed
you earlier yuma plot that i showed you
earlier where i basically say now we're
focusing on the phagocytes and within
the phagocytes this is a
forced directive this is a scaffold plot
that shows you the monocyte the monocyte
drive macrophages
and the microglia and on the right side
you find the heat map
but this is a composite of all the
samples whereas here we separate the
samples we look at for instance
what it looks like in the glioma in
glioblastoma so the wild-type ivh1
wild-type cases melanoma and carcinoma
and you can see immediately
from a distance that the mutated
low-grade glioma
has relatively little influx of
monocyte-derived macrophages and what
we're seeing
much more influx in the glioma
cases so glioma it seems to attract
monocytes to then convert into these
tams monocyte derived macrophages
and that uh in in and that still is
dominated
by by microglia and that the number of
microglia or the number of monocyte
macrophages increases
in the metastasis rather dramatically as
you can see here and then this is the
relative contribution then of microglia
to the thumb
population is obviously then reduced um
this isn't when we when we studied the
microglia in some
more detail i can just show you here
this is just again just a snapshot of
something when we look at the cns
resident phagocytes yet they are
responding
to the um uh to the two
within the tumor microenvironment so for
instance i don't show you epilepsy
because it basically looks similar to
the grade two uh um mutated
uh gliomas whereas in the higher grade
glioma you can see already the microglia
upregulating
mhc class two and other markers and and
in the heat map
and and all the raw data are with the
paper
and and you can download them for your
perusal if you want to
um but what i thought was much more
interesting is to look at
the monocyte derived macrophages and i
this again on the upper left you can see
here we basically draw the gate on the
cns
invading phagocytes and then using this
slingshot pseudotime analysis of the
of the data we start on the lower left
i'm sorry now we're talking at the very
middle
of the of the image that i'm sharing
with you right now
you can see we're starting from the
classical monocyte and we can see the
strange trajectory once again this is
the composite of
all the cases that we have we see the
strange trajectory
i will not go into detail about the
trajectory but instead what i want to
show you and what i want to share with
you here
is the fact that it does look again when
you
when you tease the samples apart and you
look at the
wild type idh1 the and the melanoma
carcinoma metastasis
you immediately see a fundamentally
different shape
in the tumor uh macrophages in the mdms
uh and and as a rather clear
fractal kind of receptor and cd163
expression
in the monocyte macrophages in for
instance in the
in the glioma cases in the glioblastoma
whereas we find an upregulation of 206
209 and 69
in in in these melanoma cases and
in in carcinoma and there's also this
increase in pdl-1 so you see
this this this bifurcation of
of macrophage education that is driven
by the tumor entity so the tumor the
tumor-associated macrophages of a glioma
and of a melanoma and carcinoma are
actually different
from one another but within the melanoma
and within the
glioma for instance they are relatively
homogeneous
and clearly indicating of a tumor-driven
education or
tumor-driven polarization of the
macrophage compartment um
and this is not just uh an
interesting phenomenon but it's actually
something that is
relevant also to the patient
outcome the particular signature here in
particular
in the low-grade leoma shows you that
this accumulation of this particularly
polarized macrophages factor kind of
receptor and 163 positive
monocyte derived macrophages is
if you if you do see um a
high prevalence of these cells in in
the in the signature of of this is a
tcga database
it does actually correlates to
poor patient outcome so as there's an
indication that this is actually
something that we call a suppressive
monocyte derived macrophage
other people have called these entities
myeloid derived suppressor cells a term
that i wouldn't want to use here because
i think
it is slightly too nebulous to to make
make sense of it
but at this point this is just a
correlation if you have this particular
signature
in a patient that does correlate with
with
poor outcomes and for us it will be uh
the next step that we're undertaking
right now so understand
the biology of these cells why are they
actually suppressive what do they do
and there are some indications there's
also a little bit of literature
but the the advantage of of the
technology that i've i've showed here in
this case
it's mass cytometry but also
high-dimensional cytometry in general is
that you can
separate these entities study them in
more detail also in preclinical models
which is i think where the next step is
to validate some of these findings
now having talked about macrophages
which is clearly also the focus of
of that of that study
i there are of course some insights into
the
tumor invading lymphocytes and i told
you earlier already
that we see many more pills in the
metastasis than we see in the gliomas
and here basically we are looking at a
subset of tails
namely the regulatory t cells and there
is this this story
um that's been out there for longest
time that because glioblastoma is a
relatively cold
tumor that we would see this
accumulation of regulatory t cells and
numerous publications to support this
and we were a bit surprised to see that
the biggest difference that we see
between the samples was in fact that
an accumulation of regulatory t-cells in
the metastasis cases
so those that see more invasion of
leukocytes altogether
actually also see more regulatory t
cells going in
and that while when you really think
about the data it's actually not really
surprising anymore
but we were a little bit surprised by
the fact that we found relatively few
t-rex in the glioma cases
um there are some if you then you can go
further and again this is more of a
resource for people to look at if you
want to go into the data you can see and
study more the changes in the resident
compartment on the resonant memory
uh t-cells that we see and
see clear changes in their in the
in the response of the of the
resident memory cda t cells this is just
one example of things we've studied
but the the the pres the presentation
here is basically just a snapshot of
a rather rich data set which is now as a
resource online where you can just
download things and
and study questions that you had and try
to answer them with the data set
available
um there are also the possibility for us
i mean obviously when you look at tails
you might as well look at
natural killer cells you can see here
again on the upper left corner
a just that we put the heat on there we
will gated on the
nk cells and found then
indeed that once again the tumor type
dictates the behavior
of these of these natural killer cells
in particular we found this population
of cd56 intermediate to bright
and c6d negative nk
cells particularly in the glioblastoma
cases and there were almost
none of them in melanoma and carcinoma
let me go further in the interest of
time so we have the impression that
immature natural killer cells do
accumulate in this also immature
based on their phenotype and k cells
accumulate in the
in the glioma in the water glioma
we can see this here some other
information about
uh the proliferation
of the t of the nk cell compartment
expression of
2b4 tim 3 and what have you and and and
proliferation
is measured by uh ki-67 staining here
and you can see the data
right there so what is the bottom line
here is and that's something i
i really wanted to share is that this
high-dimensional cytometry that
did capture 100 of the leukocyte
landscape in the human brain
so it is not that there were any unknown
entities cells of
what are they we don't know or immune
cells
or something we could really define each
cell population in quite
great detail using this technology and
that
with a fair number of patient samples
that we had available to us
to to make this comparison the cns
resident phagocytes clearly dominate in
the glioma tumor microenvironment
and they seem to acquire an
immunosuppressive
signature and the monocyte derived
macrophages
they accumulate more in the high grade
leumi but clearly dominate in metastatic
lesions
and the composition of also the tissue
resonance t
cells and so we talk about t and nk
cells
is determined by tumor origin and not by
the tumor site
which when it comes down to something we
were completely agnostic
about what the result would be it could
have very well been that
the brain dictates uh the tme and you
just
wouldn't see major differences in the
leukocyte composition other than number
but we do see a fundamental change
dictated by the tumor
itself and um with that i would like to
just basically acknowledge the team and
i
show you this picture here because at
one point i guess
if i have another minute i'd ramble
about this a little bit we
i i was frustrated by lab pictures that
we took
and that many other people are taking or
pictures of the institute which are
i never thought were really fun and i as
a student i did always
did a little bit of photography to
actually make a little bit of money on
the site and we decided after many many
years of not having
having uh used my camera take out the
camera equipment get together in the lab
and
and take the slab picture which by now
some of these
are no longer in my team some few
members have joined already
and but this is basically the lab team i
acknowledge in particular the the two
people that that ran the study which is
a catarina she's right here in the very
middle uh but since i don't have a laser
pointer you
i i showed you to show the catarina to
you earlier and then we have a bunch of
nice collaborators
if you're interested you can follow us
on twitter
and i wish to thank you for your
attention
thank you very much and thank you so
much dr butcher for that informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of
this webinar and if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the
far left of your screen so let's get
started we already have some questions
coming in
from our audience members dr betcher
for what kind of experiment do you use
as sdrna sequence when single cell
cytometry
okay can you hear me yes we can
okay very good yeah i i think this is
this is the discussion we have with
so many people always there's this huge
discussion i told you earlier in the end
when i looked at the presentation just
now when we talk about
single cell technologies nowadays
everybody refers to single cell rna
sequencing which
i think is just utterly wrong because if
you look at a microscope
and you look at the morphology of single
cells you're studying single
cells even within the context of of of a
tissue or what have you
still a single cell analysis analysis uh
ongoing here
the issue is then a question of
dimensionality or
better to say question is the number of
parameters you're studying
singles rna sequencing of course has the
highest number of parameters you can
study
uh you can basically look at the
transcriptome if you
spend the money you can even go in in
quite a bit of depth in there
but i often i sometimes find it
frustrating because you do have for
instance if you study immune cells
i rarely see a novel set of immune cells
popping out of
and then being discovered this way
because the the dimensionality threshold
for immune cells
with our panels for cytometry are often
met
quite quickly already so there's very
little need for this sometimes we use
rna sequencing to go in depth in certain
populations we're curious about what
they're doing we're curious about
their shape or the development then this
is a good technology
for let's say pre-clinical studies but
when we look at clinical data sets and
we are interested in studying large
cohorts of patients
either blood or tissue then we generally
go for
for proteome cytometry we go either for
facts
spectral analysis or what i showed you
here a mixture of
of site off and and facts
thank you so much dr badger our next
audience question
when would you choose by top and
when spectral cytometry
yeah this is a the the interesting thing
here is that
of course they are relatively competing
technologies
and it's difficult given that you know
forget the sponsoring right now but the
issue is we do
use both technologies i have some level
of excitement
about spectral cytometry because of its
speed
it is so much faster than sight off so
the advantage of spectral and of
flow maybe maybe for um
maybe the
uh so the great advantages for instance
you have a better dynamic range you have
more sensitivity
but then the post acquisition analysis
of
cytome of of fluorescence data is
very very very demanding very difficult
to do
and fraud but lots of different problems
you're facing whereas if
the site of the data that come out of
the site of
are basically ready to be analyzed which
is which is one advantage has very
little transformation
needs to happen so i like that about
siteof but
what i'm attracted by right now is the
the possibility that
spectral offers the potential for
very fast analysis of huge numbers of
cells
and that's where i find quite attractive
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
any questions we cannot answer today
will be answered via email
our next question dr butcher how would
you
treat glioblastoma um
given that current immuno immunotherapy
modalities are failing
so this is of course a great
disappointment and and i i've always
been interested
in neuroimmunology and i've i've always
felt that in order to treat a disease
like glioblastoma you have to have some
level of inflammation
and like everybody else i had high hopes
that checkpoint blockers would
would make at least a little dent into
it but
not even a scratch on the surface was
observed so the thing is it seems to be
that the brain is not an easy side to
target and it may very well be
also because you know this the
glioblastoma
uh theopostomas are cold
and and it's it's you need to make a
change within the tumor micro
environment first
and so my thinking would be
so so this is all bad about the other
stoma but there's one advantage
glioblastoma has over many many other
cancers and that is that it doesn't
metastasize so it means that if you are
capable
of altering your tumor micro environment
within the brain so all these patients
undergo surgery
why not add uh let's say cytokine
uh into the tumor bed alert
and activate and converge if you wish
the the this cold environment into even
temporarily into a hot one and then
combine that
with more traditional immunotherapy
approaches that drive systemic immunity
and then hoping that this combination
pre-clinically that actually works
really really well um so it would be
very very interesting to do this in a
clinical setting i think that's where
the future is and i think we need to do
it soon
thank you so much dr benjamin we have
time for one more question
this next question is actually a
two-part question have you ever
studied peripheral blood monocytes in
gbm
and and if so is there any phenotype
corresponding to
mbm that's a great question
so it's a fantastic question
unfortunately it's not that trivial
of all the patients that we have
analyzed here where we got
had access to the brain we all obviously
also had um
had the possibility to look at um
peripheral blood mononuclear cells now
in theory
pbmcs do contain a fair number of
monocytes the problem is in order for
the workflow to work
we need to and one of the advantages for
instance of using mass cytometry here is
the
the capability of of um
barcoding so we can combine all the
samples eliminate all batch effects
eliminate all
the majority of batch effects and really
get a really clean and crisp and
and nicely aligned data set and we did
the same thing simultaneously with the
peripheral blood but in order to do this
simultaneously with the peripheral blood
the blood has to be
frozen the cells have to be frozen and
then thought again
and then the monocyte compartment is one
of the first that seems to suffer
tremendously so while we have looked
into this
we don't think that there was a good
correlation on the
monocyte on the few monocytes that
survive the the
the procedure to show us um on to guide
us now this will become monocyte derived
macrophages that we see in the brain in
addition i actually think that they all
go into the central nervous system
equally
open to suggestions if you wish and then
once they enter the brain
then educated by the tumor side and and
get their
specialization their transformation
their phenotypic these philanthropic
changes that we see
occur within the central nervous system
and not likely outside
i think
thank you very much dr veteran thank you
for your important research and your
presentation today
do you want to provide the audience with
some closing remarks before we go today
oh i've spoken enough i'm good no thank
you very much
if there's any more questions you're
welcome to just contact me and
and let me know everyone who's listening
who is interested in
please look at the paper it's a really
cool resource check it out look at the
data analyze them and if you find
something interesting in there let us
know and let's talk about this would be
great thank you very much again sir
and i want to thank elaborate and
fluidize for sponsoring today's event
before we go i'd like to thank our
audience for joining us today
and they're for their interesting
questions and questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through july
of 2021. until next time be safe
have a great day bye